the future phenomenon in journalism the
Bush administration with respect to the
press or i would say postmodernists of
the right they just don't buy the idea
that journalists are objective tellers
of the truth and you know the most
famous quote on this uttered by karl
rove to my colleague kennel etta at the
new yorker is the press is just another
interest group and what then you know
famously bush administration officials
like talking to the washington times and
fox news and to some extent although
maybe not as much as advertised kind of
don't talk to the mainstream media and
what this is done on the other side is
tremendously empower the left media so
so the center if you wiff that's what
we've been talking about this whole time
has has deteriorated in the bush
administration and and and the the model
on both the right and the left of a
return to partisan journalism has has
been the i would say the big effect of
the bush genetic as you often observe we
don't know our own history and the
extent to which we've lived through
these periods before there's a wonderful
story that i have stone used to tell
about the period during the johnson
administration when after stone wrote a
series of articles about secrets of the
vietnam war that johnson didn't like
very much Johnson finally lost his
temper and revoked stones White House
press credentials and stones friend and
said to him Izzy aren't you upset that
the president united states has denied
you your White House press access yours
legitimated journalist as any of those
other people who still thought about it
from any replied you know at first I
really was upset that Lyndon Johnson had
take away my White House credentials and
I thought of all those reporters at the
White House and what they would know
that I wouldn't know and then I thought
about it a little longer and I realized
that a lot of what they would know
wouldn't be true now that's that's we
have that conversation of the skull
constantly to people who haven't been
washing reporters invariably say why do
you even bother trying to
interview these people and then I have
to sort of be the guy who defends it
anyway thank you very much everybody for
our panelists and the audience for
asking such good questions and listening
so it sympathetically and attentively we
are the warm-up act for the Arts panel
and and so Carol becker and Orhan tonic
will follow us to the stage so please
stay where you are and thanks a lot